that's katy perry giving a larger than
life performance on saturday night live
god bless the song dress hit up studio
8h for a trippy production of her single
when i'm gone
[Music]
surrounded by so many giant mushrooms
the performance had all of social media
talking one person tweeted quote katy
perry knew exactly what she was doing
with those mushroom background answers
another wrote quote katy perry having
some fun with fungi on snl tonight
[Music]
the set design and costumes might look
familiar to fans especially those coming
back from sin city
[Music]
yep katie is having a full circle moment
with one of her earliest chart toppers
[Applause]
she's waking up in las vegas most
mornings these days with her new
residency at resorts world the
residencies in vegas seem to be super
hot right now they are
katie gave e.t all the behind the scenes
details i'm a doll in the show and so
we're in different sets that are like 10
times the size of me so it's kind of
like honey i shrunk the kids
one of my favorite movies meets
pee-wee's playhouse also one of my
favorite movies and you know
maybe with a little cbd this show is
really the most concentrated version of
me it is jam-packed hit after hit after
hit basically we went down the the the
streaming playlist and said okay what
what are people listening to the top 20
and that's our set list the show took a
year and a half of planning with the
help of katie's creative directors and
and ash of the square division these
guys have been with me probably through
my worst of times and they're
experiencing me in a better place more
balanced place after having you know my
child and my partner and just finding
that balance in life what's funny is i
when i'm rehearsing i always have a kind
of a dummy mic
and they call it a ditch stick because i
used to just like throw it when i
couldn't like get a piece of
choreography and like it wasn't it
wasn't
but at the end this microphone just
looked packaged haggard so it was a
ditch stick but this mic that we have
now the new one has only been thrown
once and it was a very light throat
it was really like um
so i you know if you can if you can you
know handle me at my worst you can have
me at my best
[Music]
you